what up guys welcome to the just early
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sitdown where I bring on different
guests from all walks of life um today I
have one of the OG mgtow content
creators Sandman here today um he has
been in the space for 10 years um which
is crazy welcome to the show Sandman
thanks for having me how have you not
been like banned at this point well I've
been demone I was demonetized originally
in 2018 uh see the thing is when I
started doing this YouTube didn't really
like nobody really knew that there was
actually a social change or cultural
change so for the first three four years
most mtow content creators flew under
the radar they were they were going
after people for copyright more than
anything else for using like two or
three seconds of fair use Clips they
weren't going after people for things
like hate speech it wasn't until
2017 when the ad apocalypse happened
when PewDiePie started Ed to like make
anti-semitic things or things they
thought they were anti-semitic that they
actually started going after people for
hate speech PewDiePie that's like a
YouTuber right I don't yeah he was the
biggest YouTuber from I think 2013 till
2017 and uh if you look it up like the
ad Apocalypse of 2017 all of a sudden we
woke up one day and all the advertisers
were deciding to pull ads off of YouTube
because uh they started finding all this
hate on their like next to their ads so
overnight everyone's ad Revenue dropped
by like 90% until YouTube started to
clean up channels and at that point they
started putting most of my videos in
limited State I had to appeal every
single video to get monetized and that
was that was going for a lot of people
back then so are you remonetized now or
no I monetized on my Sandman 2 Channel
um if I want to get my Sandman one
channel monetized I have to like delete
most of my video content and then I have
to reapply which I'm not going to do so
I just post new stuff on Sandman 2 I
don't use the mtow term like the acronym
because if I use that automatically the
videos get demonetized so I can't use
that anymore so what um I'm curious
about two things I'm curious about first
like what got you into mgtow and then
I'm I'm kind of curious like what early
how long has this mgtow movement been
even going on well there's there's a
couple versions of it like the first
version was around like
200123 and a couple guys they decided
they wanted to REM masculinize men and
they wanted to feminize women so the
idea was that was the original mikow but
the but the second version of it the
iteration that you see right now is kind
of uh the brainchild of a guy named uh
Barbarosa and that was around 2008 2009
he started posting content and you know
there there's a video called the post-
feminist man and it's actually like
really interesting because back then
when he was putting stuff out he was the
first one to do it and it was extr
extremely revolutionary and then you had
another guy called Stardust who's now
the thinking ape and he's more of an
incel Channel now blackpilled incel
channel he's kind of switched over uh
and then and then you saw a lot of men's
rights people kind of jump on the
bandwagon early like you had Karen stra
this is around 2010 2011 12 and then it
kind of not necessarily died down but
like the main content creators they
stopped producing as much content and
then that's when I came in at the end of
2013 so I discovered this and I was kind
of going through this patch of my life
where I was like well I just came out of
a 10 year-long relationship and now I
wanted to um you know I wanted to
basically not make the same mistake
again fall for the wrong type of person
so I was like I'm going to date again
but I'm G to make sure I kind of figure
this out and that's when I ran into
stardust's videos and it wasn't I
thought oh this is dating advice it's
like no this is advice as to why you
shouldn't be dating and the more I
listened to him there was a giant
six-hour compilation of his content I I
realized wait a minute like this makes a
lot of sense and so from there the more
I learned the more I redpilled myself
the more I decided I got to talk about
this I have stuff to add so then I just
started adding stuff in October November
of 2013 okay and what is the biggest um
and I think I understand but I just want
to confirm the I mtw's men going their
own way blackpilled is when cuz people
are starting to say I'm blackpilled now
and I I don't even I think isn't
blackpilled like it's all about looks
and it's like over for a third of them
well that's that's kind of the incels
right so you get you get so there's
different groups in the manosphere right
so you get you get the mikow like this
the second iteration like I said 20091
and then you also get the blackpilled
incels who were once known as tflers or
true Force loneliness guys and those are
the black pillar guys and then you get
the mras which were kind of around in
the late 2010s and early oh sorry the
early 2010s and they they were we were
competing with M like with them the
mgtows were competing with them like I
was I considered myself an MRA back in
like 2013 14 15 and I was a mtow too but
they didn't like they didn't like mgtow
because it was kind of stealing their
Thunder at the time and then you also
get the puas once mgtow channels were
all demonetized on November 15th of 2018
then the Pua started coming up and the
Pua started to fill the space that a lot
of the mtow channels like when they
disappeared left so you know like
there's a lot of little subgroups right
so puas masas mows and pretty much
incels I think I think I understand them
somewhat the do you okay what do you
think about like is it over for like do
certain men have zero shot at dating at
all um just based on how they were born
yeah like I mean if like if you look at
Women's expectations if you look at like
what's going on in the sexual
Marketplace yeah it's pretty much over
for some of them but I don't think a lot
of younger guys like I've talked to guys
and their teens and they don't even want
to date they're more they're more just
happy doing their own thing and this
would have been unheard of you know 20
years ago that you know 14 15 16 year
old guys are like I don't want to get
married I don't want a girlfriend it's
and it's not like they're listening and
watching mgtow content they're like
they're watching Andrew Tate videos and
they're deciding this stuff early on and
think it's also partially to do with
like lower
testosterone and like we're starting to
get into this culture where guys are
just becoming more particip they're not
participating in things they're just
kind of becoming observers they don't
even play video games they watch other
people play video games it's like they
they don't want they don't want to put
effort into anything like the culture of
laziness has gotten so out of hand so I
wanna dating takes
work yeah so I wanted to get your point
of view and you're kind of going into it
now but I just give me me like a broad
overview on what is going on in society
like why can't the genders get together
well the genders could never get
together the the thing is the reason we
were together for the longest time was
because of codependency right because
women weren't allowed to work so they
needed men for financial survival and
and basically men wanted sex so there
was this like natural trade-off right
sex for resources and attention women
women couldn't go and get dopamine
rushes off their phones so they actually
pH phally had to talk to people but if
you talk to too many people you were you
know you were considered the Town
Bicycle and everyone would ride you and
like they didn't they didn't want to do
that because it was socially
unacceptable so to get a steady stream
of attention from one guy you had to
settle down and marry marry him right
you weren't going to get that from like
dozens of simps and orbiters like all
over the place so now we've gotten to
the point where that Dynamic is out of
whack and now you're starting to see
like Society break down yeah and so do
you um so when I look at the future it
looks kind of grim to me you know I'm
not I'm not I'm like a happy person so I
people think I'm like a Doomer whatever
maybe maybe you get this too like it
just seems like the birth rate's going
to keep going down and we're just going
to get fatter and Families Are Gonna
kind of go away so the problem is the
fertility rate is collapsing yeah and
it's going to get it's going to get
below one like it's already drop below
one in places like South Korea this is
going to get this is going to accelerate
and uh so like every population well
half every generation so you're looking
at within like 100 to 200 years you're
looking at the populations Falling by
like
95% right like it's wow this is like
really yeah because I didn't I didn't
even think about it like that okay so
like imagine right now you've got 50
million South Koreans and imagine the
next generation is half so it's going to
be it's going to go from 50 million to
25 in like 40 50 years 60 years then
from then it's going to go to another
half so it's going to drop to 12 so the
25 is going to drop to 12 and then from
12 it's going to drop to six and then
from six it's going to drop to three So
within four or five generations you're
looking at going population 50 million
to 3 million so all of a sudden you
can't run a civilization when your
populations drop that fast so the thing
is we marriage is a social technology
right we use it to procreate to have
relationships that build a society you
know Christianity is a social technology
you know it so we need a new social
technology that's going to stabilize
fertility rates and like we need a
culture that like promotes like birth
like there's a there has to be a reason
you have children and right now we don't
have reasons to give to people that have
children right so we're going to have to
figure that out so like it's it's not
just as simple as oh like men and women
need to get married it's like yeah we
need a new like software update for the
human species that's what we need and
the way I cuz I kind of when I first got
I don't know if you saw me reacting to
your stuff like years ago like two three
some of the stuff I would see I'd be
like wow this is kind of harsh like why
don't they want to get married um but
then I started to realize that men can't
interact with women without a legal
consequence so I was like at work
there's a legal consequence and I think
you had a video that kind of broke this
down you did like usually you do a
really good job of like simplifying
things um but yeah there's a there's a
term there's a term it's basically like
unless you can unless you can take a
complicated thing and simplify it and
explain it to everyone in plain language
you don't understand thing you're
talking and I think that's what a lot of
that's that's why like my channel kind
of took off back in the day is because a
lot of the people who were talking about
this were using complicated academic
language they weren't using plain
language that everyone could understand
and I wanted to make this very much
about um like main I wanted to make it
mainstream and they were not happy about
that they didn't want it to become
mainstream so there was there were kind
of arguments from them with me on that
one so wait they don't want it to to be
mainstream no the original like the back
in the 2010s they didn't want this
knowledge to be mainstream they wanted
to keep it kind of like especially guys
like Stardust they wanted to keep it
very much uh like out of the mainstream
because they wanted to be like their own
little Club their own little group and
and my whole goal was to make it
mainstream and they were very critical
of this they did not like this well in a
way I guess the way I see it is men are
so logical like they just kind of look
at the risks and the rewards that
regardless of what we say I think men
are going to walk away from marriage and
relationships regardless like because
I'm just like if women are bringing less
than ever before and there's more risk
than they're taking than ever before it
just seems like even if like there was
no Manis feere none of this I think men
would walk away regardless just maybe a
little slower yeah it's just I'm just
basically accelerating it right that's
pretty much like you're you're
accelerating it massively like you know
the the thing is i' I wanted to make it
mainstream and you're exactly what I
think needs to happen like I I I think
we need to make it mainstream faster
because right now like people are
sending me articles saying like the
government is starting to freak out why
aren't guys getting married like the
Capitol Hill paper is starting to like
ask this question right they're like
what's going on it's like so politicians
are starting three years ago I was like
what they don't want to get married four
years ago um but okay so what do you see
cuz I guess the way I look at it as
before like a hundred years ago there
was a patriarchy and when they gave
women the right to vote like that it's
gone right and then it seems like when
women got more and more power basically
we just kind of did bad stuff we made a
justice system that oppressed men we
made um I what do you call it
um yeah family courts abortion you know
you know so the three things you get you
get family courts you get abortion and
you get the pill those three things
affected fertility rates in the 50 60s
that and that dropped us below
replacement level correct correct so
what do you see like moving forward you
know I always talk about women shouldn't
vote um I don't necessar I mean I
believe that to my soul I don't know if
they'll do it do you think they're going
to go towards more like egalitarian
policies or more patriarchal policies
well we had egalitarianism like in the
90s like when I was growing up in the
90s like things were pretty equal like
it was equal
opportunities um there was none of this
like women are oppressed you didn't see
all this crazy feminism coming out
everyone was kind of getting along so
it's this period of time where male
power and influence started to kind of
decline but women's power and influence
started to rise and we reach that point
of equilibrium in the 90s and it only
really started maybe the last 10 15
years years that women started to like
like push for more power over a men like
it you know it's that's when you started
to see uh like start things start to
switch over the other way but wouldn't
you say that it started before that
because I thought the changes in family
courts happened before the 90s yeah yeah
that I mean that was the 70s and the 80s
like when you when you started to see
that but again that didn't creep in like
you have to remember like these things
kind of take time because the previous
generations they stayed together they
didn't necessarily get divorced it
wasn't until like the mass divorce of
the 1980s that you started to see a lot
of this stuff like start to happen last
divorce of the 1980s that kind of makes
sense with what I see because I I say I
think there's three gener I call them
like the three generation of shitty
wives um because what I just from
interviewing so many people um that kind
of makes I always say like it's it seems
like the women from uh like 7 80 to like
100 seem to be like the last generation
of women that believe in like submission
that really seem to like care more about
the family than themselves the Next
Generation they kind of were the ones
that seemed to tell their do like they
might have stayed married but they they
seemed to tell their daughters to always
have a backup plan don't depend on a man
etc etc you have to understand like
these like the older much older women
they grew up in a time like okay imagine
this you grow up you face the Great
Depression and the dust bow then you fa
the second world war then you fa like
horrible inflation of the 1940s so from
1929 all the way till 1950 if you were
like in your teens and 20s and a kid you
were dealing with hardships it didn't
matter if you were a male or female like
times sucked and all of a sudden you get
out into the 1950s and it's this like
golden age where there's like McDonald's
and 57 Chevies and yeah and everyone's
like women like to be traditional it's
like yeah you would like to sit in a
kitchen and and like do nothing in peace
and quiet because you've had like 20
years of turmoil yeah and so so women
did that until the pill came out and and
then their children like you know when
they say like the sexual Revolution that
was the Baby Boomers the children of
that generation that kind of you know
basically grew up through those Hard
Times their children started to come out
and they had only experienced good times
so now they went out into the world and
that's the generation started to make
the changes yeah cuz I call like 40 to
60 year olds women roughly I mean I know
there's like their names for the groups
but I and I'm curious if you agree I
always say like the 40 to 60 year olds
were kind of generation yeah yeah go so
like yeah 40 to 60 40 to uh 55 that's
Gen X right so and you also have to like
the manosphere stuff kind of flows
in like every generation has its own
kind of manosphere moment so the Boomers
if you look at the M they're
predominantly Boomers and then if you
look at mgtows they're predominantly gen
Gen X and then if you look at you know
let's say the second half of Gen X and
the first half of the Millennials were
mow and now the Zoomers that's where
you're starting to see the black pill
Insel guys right so every generation is
kind of taking on a different value
system when it comes to the manosphere
okay so it goes basically it started
let's say the half the second half of
the Boomers and the first half of Gen X
that's mras the second half of the Gen
xers this first half of Millennials
That's The mgtow Sweet Spot then now
you're getting into the Millennials uh
the second half of the Millennials and
the first half of Zoomers that's where
the the blackpilled incel stuff is
coming it so as every every generation
kind of moves forward and like
eventually disappears and stops being
influential that's dominant culture that
kind of takes over so do you ever cuz I
always hear tradcon say we need to
return to traditionalism do you see it
ever coming back like is it possible no
like it's kind of like I don't know I I
watched a couple of your videos I think
you were talking about orange pilling
yourself about like Bitcoin and stuff
like that oh yeah I was very confused
those whole videos but yeah yeah there's
all these pills right like but the idea
is you know we used to use gold as money
and then we use now we're using paper
money and then eventually we're going to
switch over to some kind of digital
money so like going back to Tradition at
this point is not going to work because
a woman can pick up her phone even if
she's sitting at home and she's
traditional and she can get all the
attention she wants from guys on her
phone so the only way that that
traditional tradcon thing worked was
based the technology was a lot simpler
back then right like you can't go
backwards in time like you can't
uninvent all these things uh okay
because that was kind of the red pill
moment that I had was when um I started
interviewing guys for the divorce
documentary and when I started I was
like what do you guys complained about I
know some good chicks until I kind of
would meet the good not the good chicks
but like the the husbands 20 years later
you know so like it's not like my the
girls I grew up with are divorced or
whatever you know but and then I would I
would realize there would be one like
I'm in London it's so diverse there'd be
one that was Muslim one that was um you
know British one you and so it would be
like every single background it didn't
even matter like it was the same
patterns and I was like but I kind of
had the connect that social media like
we're just so influenced I guess by
social media that it doesn't even matter
where you're at in the world unless they
ban phones which I mean we'll probably
still get them you know no I mean look
Afghanistan they're telling their like
they banned phones in Afghanistan but if
you're a good fighter in Afghanistan
they'll give you a phone so now like you
have to understand phone is like a so
it's it it allows the social the Mind
virus the woke mind virus to enter your
brain without you even realizing it okay
and and that woke mind virus like
reprograms you to basically lower your
fertility rate you know to you know to
to watch like adult material to start
talking to people and getting your
dopamine Rush on your phone instead of
human social interactions yeah and so
it's literally rewiring the brains of
the entire species and nobody really
like talks about this nobody really
cares about it and wow I didn't even
think of that it's like a it's like a
virus right like you have to understand
like human beings our social systems are
are basically like computer code right
they're just like data and they you know
information so the more we the more we
influence ourselves the more we program
ourselves with certain like technology
the more we're going to adopt certain
behaviors and so the only way you can
get get away from it is to kind of like
just shut it all off but you can't
because you need it for work and a lot
of people you know you need to socialize
with people so it's we're kind of stuck
with it yeah well because I even think
about my dad doesn't have any social
media and he's pretty I mean he uses it
but it's pretty limited and he he kind
of hates where it's kind of funny
because I'm so on it but he like hates
where the world is going um but it's
like interesting because sometimes I
talk to my dad like some of his friends
and I think like the way they talk is
just like different like it's
interesting how even social media has
almost influenced the way we speak to
each other and I can't can't really
describe it like I I wouldn't be able to
tell you like what's different I could
just tell you it is well our parents
generation it's like they're they
they're very limited when it comes they
still interact with people face to face
they don't necessarily use technology
they use technology to keep up with
their friends like they'll go on
Facebook and they might like send their
friend and message and like that's what
the that's the limited extent of their
social media usage or they might use
something like you know like Skype or
they might you know they still want to
like FaceTime people they still want
that but our generation's like I would
you know I I I just text people I don't
talk to people necessarily conversations
are have become like a luxury for a lot
of people face to-face communication so
you're seeing an entire generation
becoming stunted because they don't know
how to communicate face to face with
other people wow and I had this I had
this thought too that it's almost like
you know when you were a loser in high
school you couldn't interact with the
popular people do you know what I mean
but it's almost like how do I put it the
PO it's like a weird social Dynamic
where like people and I know it's very
clear in women in dating but I was even
thinking of like the female influencers
and stuff that which you know irony I
wasn't popular you know shocking but
like um but the it's like weird it's
like they even like loser people have
access to like popular people with
social interaction so it almost like I'm
sorry I'm like not communicate no no
like look it's like I I I people I do
like coaching calls right so people are
like you know they'll pay me they'll do
we'll do a coaching chat and it's like
they get access to talk to me right so
they get to pick my brain so now like it
it allows you to connect directly to
people that you wouldn't have had access
to before yeah and so now that also
changes um like the social dynamics
because you know if I want to meet
experts in specific Fields like you know
I can reach out to someone I'm like oh I
want to talk to so and so about you know
and I as as an influ quote unquote
influencer I can ask I send him a
message and I'm like hey do you want to
do a podcast and they're like yeah sure
because they they see that I'm going to
get them maybe a little bit of attention
or maybe they find what I have to say
interesting and then that kind of allows
me to access people that I want to talk
to and so we now have access to all
these incredible people that we didn't
have access to before because we were
all scattered throughout the world and
we couldn't kind of communicate like you
needed to be in a city like New York or
London right uh to actually have access
to the really cool people people used to
have to go somewhere to meet all the
cool people now you could just go online
and have direct access to them yeah you
almost have a better shot I was think
you prob almost have a better shot at
like dming a 100 celebrities with a good
profile than going to a high-end like
club or something yeah like yeah exactly
but the thing is celebrities like what
what people see as celebrities like
older Generations see them as like movie
stars and like musicians but we don't
see that anymore we don't care like oh
another actress that's all washed up
like we don't care we're like oh who you
know who's on YouTube and it's like the
older generation doesn't understand this
that their influencers and their their
idea of Fame has shifted and they don't
they don't kind of understand that you
know what was interesting um I met uh
have you heard of the demilios no so
they're like the biggest uh and they're
probably kind of they they're probably
kind of washed like I don't think
they're as famous anymore but the
daughter was like the biggest um tick
tocker like she had like 150 million
followers and it was her whole family um
a couple years ago I had dinner with
their family and it was so interesting
to see how like these influencers were
like the most sought after people but
even at dinner everyone was just on
their phones you know what I mean so
it's it's just interesting because it's
like it even changes family Dynamics
yeah I mean like people are just stuck
on their phones all the time now and
it's like you know like you know I
remember I don't know it was like five
years ago uh my brother was getting
married and my cousins came from Europe
and my mother was freaking out at
everybody she's like you don't want to
talk to anyone you're on your phones all
the it's and and like literally there
was this huge blow up because everyone
was on technology but her and she felt
kind of like isolated because everyone
was there but they weren't talking to
her right so she doesn't understand this
she's like everyone's crazy I'm like no
the world has changed like you have to
stay with the program right like and and
she couldn't she couldn't understand
that a she seems so sweet it's like a
this poor woman it's like what the
hell's going on um well yeah it's but
but the thing like it's the world
changes and people just they don't they
don't keep up with it right like and and
then all of a sudden they're like I have
to learn all this internet stuff and the
world is opposing all of all the stuff
that it's it wants on to her and she's
not happy about that so but yeah like
you were saying go ahead no go ahead go
yeah these influencers that you met like
so like you're saying that they were
just they didn't even want to chat with
each other or anyone in the room they
were just kind of busy dealing with
their social media because they were
probably getting like inundated by stuff
well and I was even thinking back in
high school um cuz I'm I'm 26 I'm almost
27 I I was thinking about like going to
like a party or it was like bonfires
when I was in high school and like
people would take a couple pictures for
Facebook and that was like it but I was
thinking about how even like parties or
if you go to a get together now it's
like these [__] have like photo
shoots at the door I'm like how many
pictures do we you know what I mean and
it's like you can't do anything without
being recorded and I remember thinking
this um a even before like I was on
YouTube or whatever and like you know
people do it for different reasons but
like um I I was just thinking how you
used to be able to like hang out with
your friends and just do stuff but like
there wasn't it almost like changes the
interaction of people because now
there's always someone recording yeah it
like a good example is like um when I
was 25 26 I went to the Grand Canyon and
I have photos from the Grand Canyon of
the crowds and there were like maybe 20
people in a photo
and like all like standing watching
looking at the view and then I have
videos that I filmed like 10 11 years
later and literally there's like a
thousand people there and everyone's
taking a selfie and and I'm like I was
there taking photos on film on a film
camera and because that's I love
photography that's something I've been
involved in like 30 years since high
school so now everyone is like doing the
stuff that I was doing like 20 or 30
years ago and they're all like trying to
like get attention for it and post it on
online you know it's and you know 20 or
30 years ago I was into Star Trek and
everyone hated Star Trek like everyone
was like this is nerdy nobody want and
now everyone's like I'm like what are
you doing so the culture is literally
like 20 30 years behind and it's and
then when it gets to the thing uh that
that I was doing like 10 20 years ago it
like it completely destroys it it
changes it right so it's kind of kind of
interesting so right now I see going
forward I see fertility rates collapsing
I see uh like the sex is just refusing
to talk to each other people just
sitting on their phones completely
atomizing from one another no longer
communicating with one another the
ability for humans to interact is going
to De decline rapidly so the the humans
can that can still communicate with each
other are going to have a massive
Advantage compared to everybody else and
right now I like I don't know if you're
like seeing on YouTube but there are so
many new channels there's so many
influencers like everyone's just
flooding into the space you know even
with like Twitter everybody wants
attention because we're an attention
economy and now everyone wants like as
many followers as possible they want to
make a living off of it they want to
they want to get like as much Cloud as
they can and so and I I I see that kind
of changing into something else in the
next five to 10 years so like what's the
next thing like what's where are we
heading after this like crazy social
media thing and I think what's going to
happen is like people are going to start
using AI to create their online profiles
and personalities and they're going to
start like that's how they're going to
socialize with the world so oh [__] you
know we're going to have avatars we're
going to have like like avatars that
speak and look different than we do and
we're going to create as many of them as
we can and compete with each other I
think that's what's coming in the next
five to 10 years you think five oh
that's that kind of scares me oh my gosh
well there's already guys out there who
are creating like uh AI girlfriends and
AI personalities and Instagram
influencers posting the pictures and
collecting money from it so they're not
even yeah you're you're seeing that so
that's just going to accelerate so what
do you think will happen like to
influencers you think they'll go away
because they have the AI instead well
influencers will become like for example
if I wanted to create a profile if I
wanted to create like some guy that
looked like a Chad and I could put that
up and I could I could basically talk
and it would be like this like like it
would be that Chad you know that crazy
Chad meme that they use but that guy
just talking and then everyone would be
like oh my God that's the Chad guy
talking it's like but that's a complete
construct and I think people will follow
avatars they're not going to follow
individuals so if you're an influencer
now you'll have to like you could create
other influencers and then promote them
and then you could have like a bunch of
influencers that you control and that
all say different things and you could
get AI to like write the scripts for
each one of them and like generate the
videos wow and the attention will be
even more concentrated to fewer and
fewer hands I think that's where we're
heading um what so do you is there any
way to like stop this revolution because
like when I'm heing you talk this sounds
really
depressing what's so depressing about it
like what's well and I've kind of kind
of had the same like thoughts recently
where I'm like oh [__] the birth rate
well cuz I'm like the birth rate
collapsing is kind of depressing you
know I mean like so what we need to do
we need to find alternative Solutions so
like I've been looking at this uh
there's a c there's a couple you could
talk to Malcolm and Simone Collins okay
they're they're basically living in
Pennsylvania and they've they' I think
they've got like three kids right now
they want to have like 10 or 15 kids and
um what they're doing is they're select
genetically selecting their embryo so
they've created all these embryos and
they're selecting which kids they're
going to like have based on the
qualities and traits of the embryo
they're saying oh the embryo has these
genes they so they're sequencing the
genes of the children that are unborn
and deciding which children to have so
you've got like hundreds of embryos
they've all been implanted and then
you're like picking which ones to have
to give birth to and so their their
whole thing is like they're selectively
they're selecting genes they're
basically doing in Eugenics to some
extent so this is the future people are
going to start selecting um you know
they're going to start selecting which
children they're going to they're going
to breed and which children they're
going to have and they're also talking
about building a culture that's going to
Foster reproduction so this is kind of
the thing we're working on and like it
doesn't matter what your culture is
there's going to be multiple cultures
that all compete with one another as
long as you start reproducing like my
whole thing would be like I if I was
going to reproduce like when I first got
into mtown my first thing was like okay
like I can't be in a relationship
against so how would I reproduce and I'm
like well I would hire a gational
surrogate I would buy eggs from one
woman I would you know basically hire a
lab fertilize those eggs implant them
into a surate mother and then nine
months later I have a child delivered to
me and so that's how I would reproduce I
would have children through surrogacy uh
but now I'm kind of leaning towards more
like if we allow it cloning because I
think like if you clone yourself then
all of a sudden you can you can
basically have you can raise yourself in
a sense so there's this like uh
continuity of of you basically like I
think cloning would appeal to a lot more
people because people are becoming
increasingly narcissistic so cloning
would kind of like feed into that it's
like oh look it's mini me right like you
can you know you can just kind of raise
a younger version of yourself and I like
people are gonna be like cloning is
immoral and it's like it's against God
and blah blah blah it's like yeah but no
one's having children I would rather
there be a bunch of clones than no than
no Next Generation right right so like
yeah I I kind of like cloning because
it's like having a younger brother and
also having a son at the same time
because it's technically like your
younger twin brother or younger twin sis
sister see I hear what you're saying but
it kind of makes my like I kind of feel
sick thinking about that I don't know I
don't know I'm I'm just like a Catholic
so I'm like I I understand where you're
like there's no other Alternatives if
people aren't having kids but well
Catholics like even most Catholics are
not like the population of Catholics is
falling right everyone this is it's not
it's not it's not a religious thing or
it's it's this social mind virus that's
entering our heads and it's it's getting
us to become more like selfish and
self-centered and we're not reproducing
so unless like the only way to really
the only way it kind of ends is with a
complete civilization of population
collapse and then eventually this the
the systems that make us this way
collapse and then we can't rely on them
anymore it's like they're saying like
people who live in cities they're moving
from the countryside into the cities
this Countryside is depopulating
eventually the cities are going to
collapse because there won't be anyone
producing food on the outside and the
people in the cities are going to have
to migrate back to the country or
they're going to starve because there
won't be anyone doing the work then we
have ai coming in and if AI starts to do
all the work of the farmers and the
people in the countryside then that's
just going to get then the population
collapse in the end is going to get even
worse so because like my my biggest fear
right now is AI starting to do the
thinking for us right so people are
going to get so lazy like if young kids
don't want to play video games they
would just watch somebody play video
games now they don't want to write their
own essay they get chat GPT to write
their essays like soon enough it's going
to be like no one's going to want to do
anything well no one so wouldn't that
like so because the way I think about
that I think of sewing right like people
used to sew their own clothes now
they're like mass produced but if the
people like if we didn't have enough
people to fill the jobs that like Mass
produce the clothes but no one knows how
to sew wouldn't that like be a problem
well they'll just they'll eventually
just get 3D printing to to create the
clothes right so you know program the
computer it'll print the clothes and
that'll be it like you know so what you
know like my my um my cousin she's uh
she's a fashion professor and her
students come in and she's telling me
that like first year second year fashion
students they don't know how to sew and
they're their students learning how to
become fashion designers and she asked
them like why are you here she they're
like Oh I thought it was cool to do this
it's like but you don't have any skills
you don't know how to do anything and
it's this lack of creativity and Society
people are not creative anymore like the
music the films like the movie industry
is like dying because there's no good
script writers anymore right so like
people are like and this is going to get
worse as AI starts to do the work like
it's G to get brutal like Innovation is
completely stopped like I don't want to
blackpill you but it's just like I'm
seeing this happening on multiple fronts
and I'm like like you know I talk to
young guys and I'm like here do a
workout and they're like this is hard I
go yeah this is the warm-up it's like
this isn't even the workout yet well
they don't go ahead no yeah like I I see
so it's making me kind of sad because I
I don't even disagree with you like cuz
I had this realization with marriage
it's really I don't know I it's funny
because now I'm on the other side of
realizing that marriage is dead right
and this is a sad realization to someone
who grew up with married parents you
know and like and I'm not saying no one
will get married but once you like
really start looking at the predictive
numbers you're like wow this is bad and
it's funny because I see people on the
other end of that before where they're
still coping I had that
and yeah it's like not not good um but
but it's like when I look at the numbers
I'm like the birth rates are declining
none of us know how to do anything I
could absolutely see what you're saying
happen yeah well I'm just saying it's
going to accelerate as people stop
thinking because it's like okay give you
an example like I used to do when I
would travel back in 20 years ago there
was no GPS right like there was no you
didn't pull out your phone type in where
you wanted to go and your phone would
tell you how to get there but back then
it was like okay I need to get a map and
I need to like figure out where I am so
I have to read the street signs and then
I had to like figure out where I wanted
to go or like if I got lost I'd have to
go to the the gas station and ask
somebody how to get to the next part
part of my journey now everything's
automatic you don't need like you needed
a navigator sitting in the car with you
like to get to do a road trip it was
crazy and now so everything is done for
you but that's good because you can do
you could do a lot more you could travel
more on the road you could do more stuff
that's fine but people don't they still
do the same amount of stuff they were
doing before but now the technology is
thinking for them so just imagine like
more of more technology doing more of
the thinking for us and eventually it's
just going to be like everything will be
done for us and people won't have to do
anything and then that's when people get
an existential crisis right they get
depressed because they're like they feel
useless because everything's being done
for them and they don't know why they
feel that way right they don't they
don't have any skills everything's being
done for them and now they're depressed
and all they do is reach for like
fattening foods and that's the world
we're heading into like you could you
could kind of see that with the what
happened with coid like like around here
like older people they still maintained
their weight for the most part but
younger people they like balloon they
gain like 30 40 50 pounds and you're
kind of like why are the younger people
because the younger people are using
technology they're sitting at home more
they're not they're not interacting with
anyone else and that's why they kind of
gained all that weight do you see um
like I'm just thinking in terms of
sports and like other I guess creative
activities do you like um when I think
of volleyball like 20 years ago to now
um I'm just talking about what I know
it's progressed do you think that you're
going to see a regression in the Arts
too like sports you already okay like
let's let's take music for example like
how many really really like amazing
artists have we seen in the last like 10
or 20 years we like compared to the 80s
and 90 90s like we're not seeing that
many artists like films films peaked out
in the 90s and early 2000s and that was
it like now like the these studios are
like look at Disney it's like failing
right like because the quality of the
writing is getting so bad um so that's
that's a progression that's like getting
worse and worse our entertainment is go
ahead so do you think the demand for
creativity will increase then uh there
the the demand is always there it's just
there's not enough people meeting the
supply like there's not enough prod
people producing the cont content right
now or or they're not producing high
quality content so you know that's
that's what's really happening like
you're not seeing like people want good
content they want to be entertained but
if something is boring they're not going
to watch it right right well I'm just
wondering because they say Ai and um
technology kills creativity but I'm
wondering if you'll ever see like a
demand for it come back cuz then what
what do you think then people would
learn how to like write better and do
all that stuff because like no one else
can well here I'll give you an example
like I write every day for the last 10
years I've written the equivalent of six
pages a day so if you took everything I
wrote which I have all saved in text
files it's like literally the equivalent
of like 110 or 20 like 200 Page books so
like it's that's a lot of written
material right that's a lot of stuff and
then if somebody you know people a
couple years ago started copying my
material they would take my video they
would put it into um like voice to text
and it would copy everything I I I said
then they would put it into another
voice synthesizer and then it would just
repeat everything that that I typed up
in another voice and then they would
upload it and they would monetize it and
they would collect money off of my
content and I complained to YouTube and
YouTube did nothing about it they're
like well you have to prove that this is
your video it's like these are my words
like they're literally just taking my
words and repackaging them so basically
the creatives are going to get robbed
that's what's happening right because
it's like imagine if I can just go
through my entire back catalog of 3,000
videos and just copy someone's 3,000
videos and in another Voice add an
avatar saying it so what what incentive
do I have to create a content if I'm
just going to get robbed every time I
don't have an incentive I can't make
money because everyone's stealing my
content and making the money off of it
well is there anything like
um okay because you basically you can't
stop technology right no so because
that's what I always hear like tradcons
we need to go back we need to go back
and you can't go back um like could you
do you think countries like Afghanistan
will be able to successfully keep
technology away from the general
population no because they're already
giving their like military Heroes phones
once you give them a phone it's over
because now they have the internet and
once they get the internet the Mind
virus gets in and their culture starts
to fall apart so it's it's Insidious it
changes you very slowly and you don't
even realize it okay so so so so the
next step so like we let's say we're at
like one .3 1.4 replacement fertility so
the next thing that's coming is going
people are like oh artificial wombs and
sex bots it's like well like I think
that I think that like augmented reality
like which like apple Hollow lens is
coming out next year so imagine you put
on your Hollow lens and now there's like
a stripper dancing in in your bedroom if
you're like a teenage boy and you're
like o like I can see this you know
interactive woman there like dancing
around like so that's going to like why
would you have a relationship when you
can have a different like
like generated stripper in your headset
every day and then imagine now sex bots
imagine uh like you know I basically
been working on something like what I
call the virtual sex system which allows
you to have sex remotely with another
person through like a doll and through
technology and like all that kind of
stuff so that's going to change things
even further because now people will be
like you know I can just pay to have an
encounter with someone directly through
the internet why would I go out and go
to a restaurant why would
would all this you're going to start to
see like sex will become more convenient
and the sexual Technologies are going to
like get more complex and that's going
to break down relationships even further
and family formation and so that then
that'll get us below one fertility so
that's going to so let's say every
following generation is 40% the size of
the previous one and as technology gets
better it's going to get smaller and
smaller going forward okay so basically
the the tradcon like not like all of
their return to tradition like a cope
there's nothing that can be done really
okay so the best example of this that I
kind of ran into was what happened when
Rome was collapsing so you had people
who believed in like the the Gods in
their temples you know like the the main
religion that was the religions that
were the the most prevalent at the time
and as Rome started to collapse a lot of
people the the tradcons of their day
they went back to things called mystery
Cults that was like Christianity what
Christianity is today with with the
mystery Cults back in ancient Rome but
the group that survived were the people
who went further into the future they
went into Christianity and they adopted
this new social technology of
Christianity and they were the ones they
were able to reproduce and they were
able to like move forward Christianity
was the new social technology at the
time so right now you know the tradcons
are the mystery Cults the the woke
feminist leftists are the mainstream and
now we've got to move forward into
something else we have to have this new
thing that we can kind of plug into
that's going to allow us to reproduce
out reproduce those other groups and
move into the future okay so like I'm
not being depressing I'm trying to like
say we have to evolve we have to change
we have to find something new and and
the way you see that happening is fling
um and basically it's going to be a
number of different strategies so like
like right now like the only two groups
that are out reproducing everybody right
now are like uh Orthodox Jews and the um
Amish oh really I was gonna say I
thought Africa well Africa is still out
reproducing but Africa yeah yes it's the
woke M virus is is getting into Africa
and as yeah as a society makes as a
family makes over $5,000 a year that's
when fertility starts to collapse so the
moment African Prosperity Rises and The
incomes go up that's when the that's
when the fertility rates are going to
crash so give you a good good example I
work with the Jamaican community and I
do a lot of Jamaican weddings and like I
work with musicians from Jamaica and
their fertility rate is below
replacement too so and they're very
traditional as a society they're like
you know the Baptist churches that they
they go to and all and even they're
below replacement so everything is
falling it doesn't matter it it's
because they're prosperous because they
have money once you have money you're
like well I don't I have a good life now
why do I need to have these children I
don't need them to work on the farm I
don't you know I don't live on a farm
anymore so it's like all that you know
all that kind of it's funny when you're
talking I can like hear your
videos sometimes like I could like hear
the do you use a voice over thing or is
no I just I just talk kind of weird and
just to kind of throw people off but
like my normal voice people are like I
want I want you to do all your videos I
like no because I script everything and
then when I read it I read it in a
certain way so that like I can edit it
all together yeah I'll just hear like
bits of like your your video voice I'm
like oh there it is so is your is your
prediction that the Amish won't survive
either cuz they're like the the people
in in Rome that were that were saying to
stay the old way well okay okay the
Amish are like a community within a
community so like the Amish are you know
I if you ever been to like Amish country
and Pennsylvania and stuff yeah so you
see the N most of them they don't
believe in electricity but they have the
natural gas tanks next to their house so
there's still like people working in gas
fields that are providing them the gas
right if if the Amish were just there
and there was no one else around them
they would have to have a military they
would have to have a government they
would have to defend themselves they're
relying on the outside culture to
protect them so once that outside
culture starts to fall apart and
disappear they're on their own they're
going to have to change and they're
going to have to become more comp
sophisticated and when they do that
they're going to lose their like their
Amish qualities that they have because
they're gonna have to evolve oh because
oh so it's if you don't evolve then you
don't have the technology so you can't
compete as a civilization
no and if you if you evolve then you
start to become like you start to have
urbanized you start to become more and
then eventually once that happens your
fertility rates collapse so you know so
like that's why like people like do you
think we've ever had technology like
this before and we just like maybe the
civilization collapsed or something well
it's not about the technology it's about
like urbanization and it's about like
Rome ancient Rome collaps the fertility
rates collapse there why did they
collapse because people were prosperous
like once we become affluent and once we
have wealth of a certain level and and
Comforts of a certain level we just
start getting lazy so what we have to do
is we always have to keep challenging
ourselves but it's hard to challenge
yourself when everything is more
becoming more and more convenient easy
you have to willingly take on suffering
and you have to willingly sacrifice for
the future oh my gosh I had this thought
okay I had this thought about
how
like it it's almost like when you cook
versus when you order food like cooking
almost gives you like a better mental
and I can't describe it but it like it
makes you like mentally better almost
like it makes you more well you have to
be disciplined right like you have to
you have to pay attention to like the
temperature you have to pay attention to
like the procedure and you have to like
like I'm bored of this I have to cook
something like I I've been dealing with
like um like health issues that I've had
to deal with and I've had to eat a very
regimented keto diet for the last five
or six years so that means I don't eat
sugar I don't eat carbs all I eat is
like fats and protein and I eat like
leafy greens meat uh olive oil and I
have to do that every day to
consistently keep my health at a good
place and so when I cheat I get almost
like problems like with the next few
days so I have to like be very very
regimented and when people see how I eat
they're like I can't eat like this I'm
like yeah because it takes discipline
and that's the suffering I'm talking
about you have to push put yourself
through something like hard to actually
suffer to get to the to something better
on the other side and so you know like
when I cut out sugar I was shaking for
like a month I had like sugar
withdrawals like carb and sugar
withdrawals and that's what a cocaine
addict would go through once they cut
out you know not cocaine like whatever
drug addict would cut out their drugs
that's how you feel with sugar as a as
an addiction so I've been trying for
this like hits home I've been trying for
years years that's like the one I'm
addicted you've been trying to get on a
keto diet or keto but just um maybe not
be so addicted to Sugar that's like my I
I love dessert that's like my thing I
like but it's not just the sugar in in
like uh like in like sweets but it's
also sugar in uh bread like bread is
sugar tomatoes are sugar like like any
fruit is sugar all of that like I had to
cut all of that out God so you're better
than me my problem is like I'm losing
too much weight how do I keep the weight
on like I was I was like scared that I
was going to like die of like
malnutrition and like too much weight
loss so I had to like I pumped up olive
oil and if like ancient societies they
would eat a lot of oil olive oil like
the Greeks and the Romans and that's
what their diet was based on and that's
why one of the reasons they were so
healthy is because they would not eat
carbs they would eat fat and fat
basically your body can run on fat or it
can run on carbs it's like the
difference between like sugar is kind of
like regular gas and like premium gas
would be like fat do you um so do you
think there's like are are you of the
thought CU I'm careful with my words but
basically there's like a a thought on
YouTube and among conservatives that
there's like Elites behind everything
that this is their plan to like
depopulate the Earth do you think that's
something that happens naturally or it's
like an agenda well look I don't know if
you've ever heard of the mouse Utopia
experiments no have you kind of run into
that before no no I don't know it okay
so there's a social scientist uh Dr
Calhoun back in the 19 I think it was
like 40s 50s 60s he created these rat
and mouse Utopia experiments where he
put these mice and rats into this like
environment that he built and he would
put like they had all the unlimited food
they could eat they had all the water
and they had as much space as they
wanted in there and what happened was
the populations boomed at first and they
were all kind of like they were like the
urban mice they were given like the easy
life and the population exploded at
first and then once like things got too
easy they started becoming like abusive
towards one another and like all the
same problems we're seeing in our
society right now is pretty much what's
happening in urban cities happened to
these mice in the calhon experiments and
so the the elites they're saying some
people are saying the elites decided
that they were going to shove everyone
into cities so that they could kind of
reduce the population but the problem is
I I think if the elites really plan this
it makes sense because if AI starts to
replace humans and does all the work
then we don't need 80 or 90% of the
population because 80 like the world
will get on the work will get done by
technology robots and AI will do the
work and you won't need this massive
population and we'll be able to save all
our resources for coming Generations so
I I see this as a as a net positive but
in the meantime it means the economies
are going to shrink it means that
there's going to be a lot of suffering
when it comes to um you know deflation
like the population's going to deflate
the economy is going to flate that's why
like Bitcoin why why do you see less
people as a positive when I when I kind
of went on this journey of like
redpilling one of the first things that
I kind of red pilled myself on was like
peak oil and like I I as a child I went
to like Cuba and I saw what happened
when they they R they didn't have their
oil supply I went to former Yugoslavia
back when in the 990s when they didn't
have oil and I saw what happened to an
economy that didn't have enough energy
and how people were hungry and societies
were falling apart and like people are
like oh we're never going to run out of
oil I'm like yeah but the oil is getting
more and more expensive So eventually it
gets to the point where the average
person can't afford the oil price
anymore they can't afford to drive so
and then the quality of life starts to
go down and the only way to kind of keep
the quality of life up is to keep the
supply there for everyone and if you
have a bigger growing population you're
going to start running out of energy
you're going to start running out of
basic materials top soil like water Aqua
you basically think that if if our the
population gets bigger and bigger and
bigger then we're going to be limited on
resources and even if we or the
resources will become so expensive that
it's a lower quality of life yeah it's
it's like okay give you an example back
in the early 20th century you could
spend one barrel of oil drill a hole in
Texas in the ground and you could get a
100 barrels back so that's your energy
return on energy invested now like if
you go to the tars Sands your energy
return on energy investment is like 4
to1 5 to one so you got to put one
Barrel in to get four or five back once
it drops to a certain point like once it
drops you put one Barrel in to get one
barrel back then there's no point in
getting the oil out of the ground
anymore because it's too expensive right
back in the day we used to just drill
holes in Pennsylvania and Ohio and oil
would bubble up out of the ground now we
have to build giant Platforms in the
Gulf of Mexico right and like deal with
hurricanes and things to get like oil
it's deeper and more expensive to pull
out of the ground so it just gets more
and more progressively expensive until
we start to run out of these things
entirely and it's not oil is not just
about driving like your car is made of
plastic that's oil your your toothbrush
is made of oil your computer this
plastic everything plastic around you
all of the hydrocarbon energy and
materials are being fed like in in
through industrialization like your
shirt if you're wearing like any acrylic
mixed shirt or clothing that's made of
oil everything's made of oil so you know
food your food is transported with
trucks that are oil you know p
pesticides and you know like uh
fertilizers are made with natural gas
right so like everything is made of
fossil fuels even Renewables are made of
fossil fuels so the only things that are
truly renewable would be things like
hydr power and you know those things
only make up like 5 10 15% of the energy
so if we reduce the population by like
80 or 90% then we can have a sustainable
civilization but people go ahead are you
relig you're not religious right uh I
would consider like I used to be very
very Orthodox Christian I used to I used
to go to church every Sunday well it's
funny because I actually hate when
people ask me this in in interviews but
usually it's like a debate but um I'm
more curious because um I don't know
this it's this is so anti like you know
I'm Catholic that it's like making my I
don't know this world is like that
you're describing is so I don't know
like it's giving me like the ick well
like this stuff is happening like you
can't you can't stop this I know right
like but you have to understand like um
like like I I also do what work as a
wedding photographer and videographer so
I go I do a lot of you know I do Bar
Mitzvah too and so I go and I I I go to
like temples and scholes isra scholes
and I also go to like Catholic churches
Orthodox Churches I'm I'm shooting
another wedding tomorrow like Southern
Baptist Jamaica so like I see like there
is in in religion there is like I don't
know how to really describe it but I
feel like a sort of spiritual energy
when I enter a church or a temple and it
it like I've had what people would
consider religious
experiences and so like I I definitely
think that something is going on like I
don't know I can't I can't really
describe like is it God is it the Holy
Spirit like what what is there's this
energy that I feel and um like I
definitely think it's there and it
exists and I've had experiences that you
like I said people would be like oh
that's a religious experience you you
experience this I'm like yeah but you're
telling me what experience based on your
perspective you're not open to it and
saying I don't know what this is I'm
going to keep an open mind until I
figure out what it is so I don't I don't
know why you're asking about the
religious thing are you just kind of you
you you're you just kind of want to stay
with tradition or you're just kind of I
don't know sorry I don't know um I'm
more I guess curious like like do you do
you think that's I guess there's no
stopping it I just wonder if there's
going to be it seems like whenever like
we play God as a society like there just
seems to be complications that come with
it you know what I mean so like when
we're messing with like reproduction
when we're like um what you were
describing like the Eugenics like
picking the the embryos or whatever but
why wouldn't you do that like why
wouldn't you right now I don't okay so
like Malcolm and Simone Malcolm and
Simone what they did was they took they
took her eggs out when she was in her
early to mid 20s she's now in her third
mid 30s so they have all these young
eggs that were taken out at a young age
and then they fertilized them and they
kept and now they're so the so like
imagine you going in and getting uh your
eggs extracted now and putting into
storage for later so you could have
healthier children and you could pay a
surrogate so you wouldn't even have to
carry the child yourself you you could
pay for a nanny and then the nanny you
wouldn't have to raise your child
yourself you could afford that too so
like technically you could you could out
reproduce everybody else but Elon Musk
is doing this now Elon musk's strategy
is like have as many babies as possible
but that's not the point the point is
not to have 20 children because the the
real issue is Will those 20 children
have children of their own and if the
woke mind virus gets to those children
then they won't reproduce so it's not
just about you reproducing it's about
making sure that the generation after
you also reproduces that there is like a
um like a constant um like
continuity that you know so there's a
culture that these children kind of fit
into that that promotes reproduction so
so Elon Musk having all these kids it's
like even one of his children became
and like think that's one of the
motivators for to BU Twitter and make it
X right because he saw that it was
affecting his own children and he's like
I gotta do something about this yeah
giving me a lot to think about this
interview yeah there's a lot going on
it's it's really fascinating so that's
why like I reached out to Malcolm and
Simone and like yeah like we we just
threw these crazy ideas out there and
they want they want we want as many
crazy ideas as possible because
eventually one of the crazy ideas is
going to work and it's going to like um
there's a show called called foundation
and in the show the emperor of the
Galaxy there he's a clone so every
generation there's a new clone that kind
of takes power and he's being raised by
uh a mother who's um an Android and so
like that's when I got the idea for like
like the cloning thing I was like wait a
minute this actually works like if you
if you if you raise your younger if you
raise your younger version and it and
then that version takes over for you
then that's actually a pretty good thing
because there's a continuity there's a
culture building something with
continuity yeah imagine we could clone
clone like Trump or like I'm I'm a trump
fan imagine imagine that imagine you're
clone number 20 so there's been 20
versions of you before so like and you
can go back and and you can look at all
the versions before and see what they
accomplished and then be like wow like
clone number five I can't believe all
the crazy stuff she did that's
incredible right and so you're going to
like remember if you have children
within three three generations the
children won't even know who their great
grandpar parents were because they never
met them right right but if you have 20
generations of clones 20 Generations
into the future you're the Clone is
still going to look back 20 Generations
back and see what the Clones did so
that's there's this continuity and
Connection to the Past right so and you
it'll be like and then you're also going
to feel like oh [__] like if I don't do
something going forward like with my
life then I let all these other clones
down right so there's the there's more
pressure on you like people are cloning
their pets right now like um there's a
couple documentaries I saw online in
South Korea like people are ordering
animals and they're like they're getting
the the copy sent to them like you know
a few months later so it's kind of
really interesting I have to I'm sorry
you've given me so many ideas I'm like I
have to like think about everything you
said you know I'm an idea Factory right
like I'm just trying to I'm trying I try
to find all these things and I'm trying
to figure out how we can kind of move
forward as a society civilization do you
do debates ever uh I don't do them I I'd
be open to them I don't have I don't
have an issue we want to start getting
panels together soon and I just think it
would be so interesting to see you on
with like a tradcon or something just
cuz you guys are so I don't want to say
opposite but like imagine you a tradcon
and like a liberal good combo you see
thing is people people kind of fall into
silos like they get into this like
entire worldview and they sit in the
worldview and they refuse to like change
their point of view like I'll give you
an like one good thing about Jordan
Peterson is he's he's a adcon for the
most part but once in a while he like
breaks out of it and he starts to think
about things and he's like oh no like
what are we going to do like he was
talking about sex robots and AI so like
AI girlfriends are now becoming popular
and then he's like what happens in 10
years or five to 10 years when AI
girlfriends and sex robots are combined
what's that going to do to the society
I'm like oh you that's going to collapse
fertility rates below one like that's
going to destroy marriage permanently so
we have to figure something new out and
he he's like I don't know what what that
means I go you know what it means it
means that traditionalism is over it
means that like everything is about to
change the human race needs to evolve
yeah even and it's scary even um even
when I don't know if you saw I've been
in like a Twitter war with the daily
wire I don't know if you've seen it
they've been like yeah I I like people
were mentioning that to me before like a
couple people I talked to about uh going
on with you today they're like oh just
be careful there's like this like thing
going on with the daily wire and
something about Fuentes I can't remember
something something was going on that
was like almost a year I did not realize
that was like they just like they're
just like you better be careful and I'm
like come on like I'm like like I've
talked to all kinds of people like like
it's I don't really care like whatever
I'm pretty easy goinging no I meant um
but I was debating because I just had
this thought that it's kind of
irresponsible to tell men to get married
young with the criminal justice system
being the way it is um and like the
divorce laws and like having kids like
not that men like shouldn't do it but I
just think you kind of got to tell them
what they're signing up for and I don't
think most young men are really aware um
at least that's what I gather when I I
interview these guys that are like
ruined in divorce as they didn't really
know what they were signing up for and
so I was kind of go ahead I I I think
it's kind of clear the S like the idea
of young guys getting married like I've
been I promoted the idea that young guys
should and have long-term relationships
you know like do that even even if
you're going your own way do that like
when you're in your early to mid 20s
that's a good time to do it you know
because you know women are the most
attractive if they like you for who you
are when they're like 20 25 then odds
are they're attracted to you they're not
with you because of any other reason
that's a good time to do it but young
guys their testosterone is falling so
quickly their testosterone rates are
dropping by 2 and a half 3% a year so
they don't even have the the the desire
to have sex anymore right and people are
like why like what's wrong with these
young people like why don't they want to
have relationships and it's like because
their testosterone is collapsing they
not physically strong and that's from
the lack of doing like hard stuff well
it's a combination of things it's like
yeah it's it's it's a lack of physical
labor but it's also the foods that we
eat the Plastics and the water the the
the birth control pills and the and the
water supply the you know all the stuff
and it's it this drop in testosterone is
accelerating so it's it's bad like you
know like that average 20-year-old now
has the testosterone of a 60y old like
40 years ago so like by the time they
turn 40 they're going to be like 80 year
olds like with testosterone if not lower
so and infertility is getting Going Up
and Up So eventually the only way humans
will be able to reproduce is going to be
through artificial technology so having
sex and reproducing will not be viable
if the sperm counts keep falling so
we're going to have to use technology to
reproduce one way or another if we want
maintain our like industrialized way of
life and there was there were studies
that said like the back in the day like
in h i was it I think Holland or the
Netherlands they they they they
interviewed uh military-aged men and
they they C checked their sperm counts
back in the 1950s and they found that
the men who watched television more had
lower sperm counts so e it's either they
were they were sedentary they weren't
doing as much physically so their sperm
counts were like half of what the other
men's sperm counts were so yeah a lot of
it is is just lack of physical activity
and also like I know people now in their
30s and 40s that have cancer that are
dying of cancer and they're like this
would have been unheard of 20 or 30
years ago but it's people are just
eating really bad food and they're
becoming extremely uh they're they're
living extremely sedentary Lifestyles
they're walking they're aren't
exercising they're not doing anything
yeah it's why like and this is before
coid so you know people are like oh it's
a conspiracy with Co it's like no this
was happening before that I was going to
say about Jordan Peterson though um yeah
I I was I kind of my conclusion which is
a little different than yours was that
we really aren't going to see marriage
rates come back until you switch the
laws now I'm thinking that wouldn't even
fix anything no because people are
getting their their their attention and
their dopamine like from from porn and
from technology like like uh what do you
call it like their phones right so like
there's a there's a interesting um
psychologist Sam vacan uh he's one of
the foremost authorities on narcissism
and he says like he's like he'd sit
there in an airport and he'd see this
like hot couple in their 20s and they're
sitting there and they're not even
talking to each other they're just on
their phones like to them they don't
even exist to each other they're just're
they're getting more dopamine from their
phones than they are from each other and
if that's if that's the peak of
attractiveness and sexual Beauty and
they're like more interested in their
phones than each other at that age it's
like we can't out compete that like the
dopamine you get from the phone is way
more than you can get from a
relationship ship so and that's just
going to like atomize society and people
are going to like separate more and more
so marriages can't survive when
everyone's on their phone it just
doesn't work and then the but even the
people that put their phones away the
issues their kids are still growing up
in this Society yeah like I mean yeah I
grew up before like before the internet
and when the internet came in like you
know I was with early Generations that
of adopter and I always use the internet
to like communicate with people and then
connect to them in the real world these
younger people they don't see the real
world is real the internet is more real
than the real world to them so they live
their primary existence in cyberspace
and then their secondary existence is in
the real world so it's kind of hard to
like build relationships when all of
your relationships your primary
relationships are online right like how
how do you you can't like you're stuck
your your like world is online and
you're like yeah that's your world so
how how do you have a marriage on the
internet unless you marry someone on the
internet like maybe you have an internet
marriage maybe that's something you
should try I I met a guy that did that
he was married and he didn't meet her
ever so let me let me let me propose an
internet marriage between you and me
like we'll have a an online wedding
ceremony you're kind of depressed we'll
walk down the virtual aisle how's that
you know you all the guests are sitting
there virtually like in every that's
that's that's the whole probably be a
big turnout to be honest oh it would be
the first internet wedding in the world
right like
wow I'm like and and our goal would
never to be to never meet but only have
an online relationship and that would be
our entire marriage we we could have
children virtually through you know we
could have like a like a AI child that
would basically like need attention the
the Eugenics people or whatever the they
they say I have good stock I don't
really know what it means but they're
like that crowd is like pearls like good
stock good like you know you you could
get behind a a horse and cow and plow
the fields right that's what they mean
right no I said I think they have like
something about red hair being like good
to them I I don't get it it's not my
thing but I guess they like the red
heads yeah I mean I I love the
criticisms that are like levied against
you people are like oh like Pearl like
she's just not the traditional Beauty
I'm like like who cares like that's your
criticism like that she doesn't live up
Beauty well yeah I was like I was trying
to be hotter like I can't help
it no but the thing is your your appeal
your appeal is the fact that like you
know there there's all these things like
you're probably seeing these memes on
Twitter and they're like oh like the mid
the guys want the the woman that's the
mid they don't want the super high
attractive super high attractive woman
they want the average woman and I think
that's what that's that appeal is what
has led to a lot of your success because
you you're approachable right like guys
see these like super hot hot influencers
and they're like I can't talk to her
like she would never talk to me I I
don't I don't I don't I couldn't see
myself with someone like that so all
like the it's like the more beautiful
you get like in terms of traditional
like beauty standards the less appeal
you get because guys start to turn away
from that because they see it as
superficial right huh so I was the I was
the I should thank my parents then thank
you Mom and
Dad there you go um well this is
probably the most thought-provoking
interview I've done in a while it's and
I really think that it's kind of
depressing me because I don't think
you're wrong
like that's the worst I don't what is
depressing you about it is it just the
fact that things have to change or like
like what what is depressing about it
this is what I I think it's exciting
because all these new things are
happening and the world is changing and
it's good I don't know I just I kind of
I don't like the idea of like you know
I'm a Catholic and I wouldn't you know
I'm not like a Die Hard or like a you
know they always try to like have me
measure it or whatever but I don't know
I'm like a normal Catholic and I just I
feel like sometimes when you're playing
God I I don't know it's just like bad
and so I just don't like all this
technology where you're literally like
playing God I think the idea of like a
virtual relationship sounds really
depressing um yeah so I don't I don't
think like that world sounds like good
to me but who knows maybe people think
the world I grew up pressing you know
like of the past well I'll give you an
example so back I don't know like a few
hundred years ago if you had a gallstone
removed like they the surgeons created
like gallstone procedures to take the
gallstone out you were in pain and the
the church was complaining about this
they said like this shouldn't be allowed
operations shouldn't be allowed on
people because you're taking God's Souls
away from God you have to just let these
people suffer and die right and people
were like no this is crazy all we have
to do is do this like surgical procedure
remove the stone and the person is
perfectly fine and so that's that was a
technology that pissed off the church
because it it basically made people live
longer right so new technologies always
piss off the P the past groups because
they don't understand they it's almost
like they don't want things to get
better they want to stay where they are
because change is difficult right like
they want to they want to kind of be
stuck but do you do you think it's
better like a virtual relationship like
testosterone levels dropping being like
everyone's get fat does that sound
better to you okay it's not better but I
I look at like all of these things like
I look at the knowledge base we have and
like for me I've I'm thinner now than I
was when I was in high school yeah I've
you know I have all this technology all
these access to all these amazing
doctors online that I never would have
had access to like 20 years ago so it's
improved my life but for the majority of
people they're just addicted to fast
food and they can't stop so you see it
as the people that like want to use it
in a good way will and the people that
don't won't yeah so the people that are
like keeping up with this are actually
like benefiting but the majority of
people they don't have the time and they
don't have the motivation to do anything
new and original they're just lazy most
people 99% of people are lazy
unfortunately that's just the way it is
like you can't like how do you motivate
people like you know like I know people
spend they go and see Tony Robbins and
they spend like thousands of dollars to
motivate themselves they feel great for
a couple days and then they're like I
need another motivational speaker right
and it's like to motivate yourself you
have to motivate yourself not you don't
you you can't rely on other people to
motivate you you have to just do it
yourself yeah and you know Christianity
says keep your Wonder be like a child
like if you if you lose your wonder and
your ability to like be creative and Cur
curious then then it'll it'll consume
you the negativity will consume you the
laziness will consume you I would love I
would love to see you bounce IDE I could
like think of like five people I would
love to see you bounce ideas off of huh
no if if you want me to bounce off ideas
like there's an interesting podcast I
need I think you need to check out it's
Malcolm and Simone Collins I was talking
about them okay uh like you should
definitely try to get them on as well
because they're they're fascinating like
every like I can't watch all their
videos because every video I watch like
literally red pills my brain in some
creative way and I'm like oh my God
that's mind-blowing and I'm like oh
there's another video tomorrow I'm like
I can't watch another video just I'm
still digesting the stuff they told me
yesterday do okay do you think I was
thinking about um how women policemen
speech I think you had a video on that
do you think that I'll ever like cuz we
always talk about freedom of speech and
I I believe that really all these limits
on speech is just women telling men how
to talk and it actually really irritates
me because I feel like I take a lot of
heat in these spaces and I don't [__]
or what I might like make jokes or what
but like I'm like all these chicks just
it's like they want to be in a man's
world but they won't take what comes
with it it just bothers me to my soul
it's like then go home go to the kitchen
whatever what happened was the internet
was the first time men really had um
well men had men's spaces back in the
day women infiltrated them they invaded
them they changed them like there's a
video I did a long long time ago called
uh I think women invading male spaces it
was one of my first videos and how women
shut down coffee shops because they
didn't want men talking to each other in
coffee shops really yeah women like the
whole uh like ISM rose out of the
temperance movement and Temperance was
basically women Banning alcohol because
they wanted to shut down bars because
men would go hang out at bars together
so it was always about policing males
talking to other males and you know
there was another one there was a
Bachelor's Club in New Jersey an article
like back in 1920 21 um I found this
article a while back and it was like
women were shutting down this Bachelor's
Club because it was all men who were
like divorced who were like getting
together and talking about how bad women
were and this is a 1921 and so it was
like mtow Club back in 1921 and women
were like yeah like there's a there's an
article that came out like I just
discovered this and they literally one
one guy one of the members was a police
officer and they went to his like police
station and they said did you know that
your sergeant over here is going to this
men's club and you know you shouldn't
allow this and blah blah blah so this is
this is nothing new women have been
policing male spaces and behavior for
hundreds of years it's just that when
once it got on the internet it couldn't
be stopped because now men could be
anonymous they couldn't be shamed
and women couldn't police it so my my
prediction was okay there's they're
going to get into like Google and
YouTube and they're going to start
policing it that way and that's not
going to work because men will just find
new groups online and then now women are
getting into politics and now
governments are starting to go after
people so the Canadian and the British
government have passed like hate speech
legislation so now they want to start
going after like Anonymous men that talk
about female nature and so women are
like they're using whatever tool they
can to stop this like because they don't
want the men to walk away and go off the
plantation they want them on the
plantation right so this is this is how
women evolved like to make sure that
they control the social aspects of
society and Men control like the
physical aspects of society the physical
world and so those two things would kind
of counterbalance one another and now
those things are out of whack because
now men have their own social spaces
that can't be fully censored or if they
get censored men just go some else it's
it's like you have to play a game of
wacka mole I don't know if you remember
this game called whack-a-mole as a kid
where the moles pop out of the ground
you keep hitting the moles and they just
keep coming up and they never stop they
just get faster and faster until you
lose the game and that's where we're at
like now with like governments and women
trying to censor because men will just
get vpns and they'll access something
from like from another so you can't stop
this like the the red pill is out there
it's never going to be stopped uh so how
do you as a woman control men in male
Behavior you can't right and and you're
not and like most women are not going to
change their behavior to suit men I mean
some are now that's why you're seeing
like the Trad wife thing kind of popping
up but the problem with the tradwife
thing is it's a luxury most people can't
most women can't afford to be tradwives
because the cost of living is so
expensive well right so and like what
what I realized with the Trad wives is
the issue is you're going to have the
same problem like women when we get
power we just kind of suck with it I
don't know what it is like um I like cuz
I just started interviewing like I don't
know I think the divorce documentary
kind of blackpilled me a little bit
because it it was like have you put that
out yet or are you still working on that
I'm I am still working on it it's
probably the next like uh six months I I
there's so many ideas I want to go over
and I'm just trying to I'm having a hard
time you do such a good job of making
everything concise I tend to go on
tangents a little bit too much and I've
been trying to figure out a way to like
make it shorter if that makes sense and
like more concise well I've I've I've
given people like I've basically
promoted YouTubers like uh think before
you sleep as one of them like he's he's
pretty big um and like I kind of
promoted him on my channel in the
beginning I gave him some ads and I also
gave him some advice and I said like
he's like how can I get more views and I
said like just write everything out
script your videos because if you start
writing you start it it changes the way
you think because you start using less
and less words to get points across
because you don't want to write as much
you're like well I want to get this
point across but I don't want to sit
here write all day so how can I get this
across in like you know a paragraph and
so the more you write the more your
brain is going to start using less and
less words to get the point across and
so but people say oh you write too much
it's like well that's what helps me
think yeah yeah so if you started
writing stuff down or if you had like a
team of writers or somebody like if you
had a writer's room right like and they
could just write things concisely for
you yeah then that would allow you to
kind of clarify the points a lot better
yeah cuz right now I have so much
content I filmed for it and I'm like how
do I put this [__] together like I I'm
so I'm such a like creative that I'm a
bit of a scatter brain so I'm like no
that's that's fine it's just you have to
kind of like what are you trying to
accomplish with it I think that's the
biggest I'm more I more just wanted to
like the the documentary is going to be
about me like kind of trying to figure
out why men are walking away from
marriage and just go over like what I
found so I want I kind of want to go
over like um just how the false
accusations um the balance of
probabilities how they expand the
definition of things um and I'm trying
to go through like each one of those and
then give examples of like and then then
I want to show like the men that I've
interviewed that have been like affected
by this sort of thing um but that sounds
like an MRA documentary that was made
about seven or eight years ago now uh by
Cassie J the it's called The Red Pill
yeah I've seen it I've seen it yeah um
um yeah I I think mine would be a little
different because I'm trying to um I I I
feel like actually I don't know maybe it
will be similar I I haven't seen that in
so long well you're interviewing guys
who've been through the divorce court
ringer right so and this is that's
exactly what she did right so it's like
if I was making a documentary like I my
whole thing was I wanted to make a mtow
documentary interview the mgtows that
were the most prominent and that were
out in the open like so you know Terence
pop there was another guy out in in
Calgary he didn't want to go on camera
because he didn't want his family
finding out oh Terence teren is so nice
actually I think I've met him yeah he's
a really cool guy yeah have you done
anything with him yet um no I met him
when I was a lot small he went to the
CME I think Donovan's thing if it's the
guy I'm thinking of but I just met him
yeah he was at that yeah yeah yeah so
he's he's got some interesting like War
Stories and stuff you should definitely
try to do a collab with him on his show
like that's actually pretty good those
are pretty they're a lot of fun yeah I'm
going to the CME next or like in two
weeks so I'm I'm assuming he'll be there
I was gonna interview but uh there was
another guy vention mow he passed away
like a while ago um but there like I
wanted to interview the mtow guys and
just kind of make a documentary about it
but the the problem was uh EI they
either didn't want to go on camera or
there just weren't enough of them that
were willing to do it so and and again
it would just draw a lot of attention
and here's another thing if you make a
documentary it's hard to monetize
because if you put it out there people
just going copy it and like share it
online so it becomes a lot more
difficult to like make money I know
people who made documentaries and they
went bust because they spent so much on
the documentary and they didn't make
their money back so like I don't think
that's going to be an issue for you but
I'm just saying like a lot of people are
like that's kind of have how they have
to think about it so writing books
making movies is not as lucrative it's
more of like a Prestige thing now as
opposed to just like a thing that people
do to to make money yeah I don't know I
have I haven't gotten that far yet I've
just started the
interviews um yeah but like it's like my
whole thing would be like like if I was
making a documentary now I would be like
trying to figure out how do we get the
fertility rates up how can we build a
new social technology that will like
keep the society and civilization
running like how can we how can we
stabilize Society from and have it not
collaps like that's what I would be
trying to focusing on and I would be
interviewing people like social
scientists and who are worried about it
and then like and then I would work in
the whole like men aren't getting
married thing and why aren't men getting
married and why aren't women having
children younger and like what's going
on and all that kind of stuff that's I
think that that that that documentary
would be a lot more more Forward
Thinking people would be like like I
would interview like I would go to like
Israel and I would interview like
Orthodox Jews I would interview the
Amish I would like Amish is on my list
actually go
ahead I would like right now the
fertility rates for the um for the
Mormons are falling below replacement
right so Utah's fertility rate is going
below replacement so if they can't make
it like and they're like one of the most
religious groups how and and that's the
thing like who's gonna make it right I
would interview like Malcolm and Simone
and like go to their house and I'd be
like interviewing them and I'd be like
okay how do we create a new social
technology that's going to get fertility
rates back up right and I that's what I
would be searching for I've honestly
before this I kind of thought that women
should have vote was the answer but
you've changed my you've changed my
perspective a bit Sandman yeah like the
whole women shouldn't vote thing that
was something like take women's rights
away that was something that turd
flinging monkey talked about back like
five six years ago and everyone was like
oh my God that's so wrong like I don't
think women's like my whole thing is I
don't want women's rights to be taken
away I want everyone to have their
rights but I I think we can solve this
problem where for the most of society
most of History men and women had to
sacrifice for their children if the the
solution would be one where men and
women wouldn't have to sacrifice for
their children but they would still have
children and every the children and the
parents would be happy everyone would be
happy or not even happy but content to
kind of and free to kind of all come
together in some way like that that
would be the ideal right and so that's
kind of what we'd have to strive for
like that's the outcome we want we want
men to have rights women to have rights
we want children to be like raised
properly so they have children and that
they're well balanced how do we get
there right and then start we start
looking at examples of societies that
have done that and then we look at like
how how we could create that right like
how we could like Malcolm and Simone are
F fantastic because they basically say
you know they're they're now thinking of
like selecting their embryos that
they're going to implant based on the
likelihood of those embryos having
children of their own based on the like
the predetermined genetic behaviors that
they could find like they want to they
want to be able to map that out so they
just want to take this further and
further along so yeah I'm just I think
we there's there are ways to solve this
but they require a lot of work and they
thought require a lot of thought and
it's not it's not easy like if it was
easy somebody would have done it by now
here I thought it was women shouldn't
vote was the answer I really
diduh look this is I'm still selling
those t-shirts though I'm gonna be
honest get yeah the shirts are going to
sell like hot cakes because everyone's
gonna believe it but but like I'm saying
like you gota look five or 10 years
forward and say okay how where is this
going to go in five or 10 years and like
you know you're pulling out my videos
from like 10 years ago and everyone's
like I was reading through the comments
they're like how did this guy know this
what was going to happen 10 years ago
today and it's like because like you can
you can see like the future is already
here it's just not equally distributed
yet so you have to find the people that
are on The Cutting Edge and that's where
that's where the society will be in 10
years from now so finding the people
that are like riding the edge of change
those are the people that you kind of
have to interview those are the I think
those are the people for a documentary
would make the most sense Malcolm Simone
Collins that's who you said it was yes
yes I'll look into so they've got a
they've got a channel called based camp
like again like you're like I'm intense
for you they're intense for me and I'm
like I can't like if I wa I listen to
one of their videos I'm just like holy
cow like there's always a point
somewhere around the 20 minute Mark
where I'm just like it Blow like blows
my mind away like and um they're having
it like they're going to have a retreat
in uh Costa Rica I think next year so
I'm I'm probably going to go to like I
don't usually do appearances but I'll
probably go to that I'll be like I see a
guy that says based Camp Chris that's
not them no it's the channel is called
based Camp so and they have uh there's
they've got all kinds of really
interesting experts on there too so
there's Aya I remember she's like
basically this like SNM woman she
basically uh Maps the sexual Marketplace
out and like she she basically collects
like all kinds of data she was like a
former uh working girl and so she's got
a lot of experience with men if you know
what I mean and so she kind of is an
expert on that so and she's got all
kinds of data she's been collecting so
it's kind of really interesting and you
know they talk about AI they talk about
fertility they talk about talk about all
kinds of stuff and it's like Malcolm is
just like an idea Factory like it just
it just keeps coming out TR wives can be
worse than thoughts I'm G to have to do
reactions to them okay what what do you
mean tradwives can be worse no I just
was reading I'm looking at the place you
said and yeah based Camp let's see their
topics yeah like it's like it's really
rich dense stuff and like Malcolm's like
he says he's like lucky with Simone
because she's on the autism spectrum and
so he he's like it's not like uh having
a relationship with a with an average
like ordinary woman it's because he's
having a relationship with somebody
that's more cerebral than you know than
the other women out there so let's see
what what are they doing so they should
find autistic women well yeah like so
imagine you could select traits for
imagine you could select daughters with
autistic qualities because here's the
thing like for me if I was ever to get
into another relationship I would I
would want to be with a woman who um was
more into what she was doing than she
was into me because I would find that
whenever I'd get into a relationship the
woman would be more interested in
policing my behavior than she'd be
interested in what she was doing so I'd
want to be with somebody creative that
would spend that would be an introvert
so they'd spend more time alone and they
would be working on own creative
Endeavors as opposed to like like
constantly smothering me in a
relationship because that would allow me
to have space and allow them to have
space yeah and we could come together
occasionally but the problem with that
is people who are really good at what
they do obsessively compulse over it all
the time so they there's no time to kind
of have a relationship that's the
problem because if you want to become an
expert in your field you don't have time
for relationships that's the problem you
know it's interesting I that's like the
one thing I get asked all the time if
I'm AU IC and I I find it a little and
it hurts my feelings a little bit I'm
like what the why do you why why do you
see an ins I don't know I just I'm like
why do they keep asking me this I get
that a lot though I don't know I don't
know why but like I I don't know you
just wouldn't I don't know you just I
don't you wouldn't think it's a
compliment you know well okay that
sounds really rude because I'm not
trying to be mean but it's just I don't
know you know but the people who like
the internet was created by people who
were on for themselves so they could
communicate with one another like this
is the thing like people who succeed in
social media like more than everybody
else look like for example when I
communicate with people um I if I sit in
a room and there's like two or three
other people I get overwhelmed because
I'm thinking about like what's everyone
thinking what's everyone feeling what's
everyone saying and I get into what I
call analysis paralysis where I'm like I
can't talk anymore because there's too
much information there's too many people
when I'm talking oneon-one um and if I'm
not making eye contact then all I'm
doing is focusing on people's words and
I'm not focusing on body language I'm
not focusing on anything else and then
that'll that that like so autist
autistic people and people who have on
the spectrum they their ability to focus
on one particular thing is really good
but if you give them too much
information then their ability to focus
gets overwhelmed and they can't focus
anymore so it's just you're autis
autistic people are just hyperfocused
for the most part so that's not a that's
not a bad thing in this world being
hyperfocus is good because you can
become an expert in your field so
there's nothing wrong with like being on
the Spectrum like like not a full-blown
autist right like but I'm talking about
like somebody that's got like um that's
on that Spectrum that's like that has a
little bit of those traits yeah so I get
it I don't as far as I know no I just I
just get asked that a lot so I'm like
huh but why did they say why they think
that or no no no I've just had I don't
know I think three different people say
that to me so so like re recently too so
I was like huh why do people keep asking
well look you you do the same thing
every day like I I don't think I don't
really see you taking any breaks you
work every day right uh Sunday Sundays
um I we we'll we'll record extra and
like post it on like Sundays yeah
exactly so you're basically every day
you're pumping out content so like to be
in this space for a really long time you
have to be hyperfocused you have to be
you have to focus on the same thing over
and you're talking about the same things
every day and the problem is most people
can't do that they get bored and they
say oh I can't talk about the same thing
longer than a few months I get tired of
this I want to do something else and
well I do I am bored of the shows we're
kind of phasing those out because I just
you ever tried was it just complicated
bringing guests in and stuff like that
or no um it's more just like one the
type of like and and people think we
like cast for this or something it's
just random people but you just get so
many like crazy chicks that you just
kind of get really really tired after
you do it for a while and then it it is
kind of a lot like booking when they're
coming and going it's just kind of
easier to sit and like do one of these
you know not that I actually I did it
for a year and a half so like I enjoyed
it but it's just it's kind of tiring you
know yeah you can't keep up forever
right yeah yeah and I'm like I just
rather give my opinions or do I don't
know talk to like smarter people no
offense to the guess some of them are
smart but well it's just it gets to the
point where it's like um the more
intelligent your conversations get the
Le like it might actually be detrimental
to reaching a wider audience right
because you're going to get people that
are going to be like I don't want to
talk about complicated things it's
making my head hurt right I want to see
some like thought like on fresh and fit
like yelling on camera right like so I
mean that there's I think there's a
certain amount of appeal to just kind of
like getting you know bad behavior on
camera that people want to see like and
that's what the majority of people will
kind of focus on but if you really want
to make change in the world like you
have to become intelligent enough to um
influence the influencers and so like if
like if I influence people like you and
and other people and then they go off
and they make they get H you know
hundreds of millions of views and then
they influence other people and then
it's like a domino effect and then it
just keeps going out and out and out and
eventually the society changes and uh
you know like I've been thinking about
this for a while and then a few days ago
Malcolm basically said oh like how do
you measure influence like how does
somebody measure influence like you know
that right now they're going after
Russell bran they want to cancel Russell
bran but where is Russell bran getting
his ideas from right and and that's
those are the influencers those are the
real people behind everything and the
establishment doesn't see those other
people all they see is Russell bran and
they go after him right and they don't
go after anyone else and I'm like well
if they knew who the in actual
influences were like they would be going
after us like massively like they'd be
like the thought leaders they want to go
after the thought leaders so true
because what you usually see is the I
call them like the credit police where
because what I found was like Kevin
Samuels was like a major influencer and
I know like Five Guys in the space that
take credit for like what he did and
this happens to me too sometimes where
like people I don't even watch say that
I'm getting it from their show like like
if you said that that would be fair like
I like you see me literally watching
your stuff but it's like funny because
some influencers like think it's them
and I'm like I don't even I haven't
watched you in like three years you know
what I mean um but it's um it's
interesting because I I feel like
there's two types of people like there's
the type that kind of realizes where
they're at and try to leverage it and
the other type like kind of gets mad you
know and that's where you see all the
infighting you know well it's it's all
like where did this idea come from who's
who does this idea belong to yeah and
this is this is like pettiness and it's
it's like okay look I I'm I will give
credit to where I get ideas from I don't
care but I will also try to add my own
ideas and thoughts to things right I
think that that's like you have to stop
and ask yourself like what do I think of
this like you know like forget about
what other people are saying I've I've
I've listened to what other people have
said now what do I think you know and
that and that was something that was
like a gift that I got from this uh girl
back in in my 30s that basically said
like it's great that you're consuming
all this content and you're just
regurgitating everyone's words but what
do you think and I thought I I stopped
for a second I said wait a minute I have
a right to have my own opinion what like
and I just kind of like then I started
thinking for myself and then I started
putting things together for myself and
observing things and commenting on them
myself and I think once you can start
doing that then you become an idea
Factory because you start seeing what
everyone else is um like you start to
see everyone else's blind spot and and
that was that's one of the reasons I try
not to consume too much content because
then other people's ideas pollute my way
of thinking I need to just see an idea
and and objectively think about it
without having other people's opinions
getting involved so like when I see
something happening I'm like well I
immediate I'm like I'm not gonna go to
you know Tim cast to hear what you know
the panel has to say I'm just gonna sit
and I'm gonna think about this myself
because sometimes I will reach a
conclusion that's different and then I
can add that to the discussion and bring
something up that no one has brought up
before well that's how um you know the
the Crowder video like Steven Crowder
yeah yeah yeah well it which video the
the like abuse accusation one you know
what I'm talking about of did that
happen recently no this was a couple
months ago where everyone was saying he
was an abuser so it was like um like six
months ago stevenh Crowder had um uh
basically like everyone like Candace
Owens reported a story of a ring camera
from his house um that was like leaked
of him like like yelling this with his
wife and all that stuff yeah but it was
like I feel like I had because of like
my background in the divorce documentary
I was like I know what this [__] is
doing I know I'm like I do not buy it
but it's like I wouldn't have had that
point of view if I didn't like do the
documentary if that makes sense um yeah
I mean right now I think things have
swung in in the opposite direction like
for the longest time um you know it was
always like women abusing men in like
divorce courts and stuff and like the
false accus and now there's actually
evidence to support that a man is being
like bad even when the man will
self-incriminate people still won't
believe it like the guy will say like I
you know I did this and I did that it's
like no he he's not an abuser he's not a
a trafficker but he's like but he's
telling you that he's trafficking these
women and you still won't believe it
it's like oh it's just the media making
up lies that's Andrew Tate thing is the
best example of this well I took it as
because Andrew Tate Andrew Tate says you
know like I got these women to fall in
love with me and then I brought them in
for my webcamming business I'm like that
is the definition of trafficking if you
look at the law right and it's like what
it's wrong to to make people fall in
love with you it's like if you're
exploiting them sexually yes that's what
the law says and you're you're self
snitching and you're incriminating
yourself way honestly the way I looked
at that though was like okay come on
when you hear human trafficking you
think like you're stealing women you
know so that's kind of why I had had
that point of view because I'm like okay
that's not real human traffic like
that's just a big L that's kind of the
way I look at it I'm like look okay but
that is an L Big L like I I would be
very upset but like L but I just I think
like if you if you choose to do it like
no one put a gun to your head so there's
a there's a great uh there's a criminal
lawyer that's another interesting guess
you might have is uh Bruce Rivers he's a
a criminal defense he's great SE him so
he talks about all this Tate stuff all
the time and it's like I I did I thought
okay they're probably making stuff up
about Tate and then he literally goes
through the case and he's like this is
what he said this is the definition of
trafficking he therefore he is guilty
and he's saying it on camera and you
know that this footage is going to be
brought up in the trial they're gonna
have it in court and he's
self-incriminating and he's going away
like him and Tristan Tate are going away
for like 20 years I think they're going
to get off you think they're going to go
to jail I think they're going to get off
I don't think they're going to go to
jail don't know but I think I think that
like they've broken the law based on the
way the law is defined like I like I
think I think the real issue here is
what like if if men can exploit women
sexually but no women can exploit men
sexually and through marriage and
divorce and get away with it but men
can't do the same to women and that's
what I think Andrew Tate was doing he
figured out female nature and then he
figured out ways to exploit female
nature for profit yeah just the way that
women would exploit men for profit
except there are laws to prevent men
from exploiting women but there are no
laws preventing women from exploiting
Men And the fact the laws reward women
for exploiting men well and my and I
think that's the bigger argument here I
think that's really the issue well and
my my thing was I'm like how the hell
did you get an ex boyfriend to let you
to convince you to do cam work I'm just
like okay like well look he's he he
basically had like okay so they were all
they were all figuring out that this guy
was smart he was going places so they
figured like if I just hook up to this
guy I can let him ride like I can ride
this train and ride his coils all the
way to success and on top of that he
found young women like the one woman I
think he had kids with uh was Vivian or
the other one I can't remember the name
of there but she was like 15 when they
got together 16 right so he would find
women that were extremely young and
impressionable and he would bond with
them so he figured out okay if I bond
with the woman in wait is that the one
pressing charges the Vivian CH they have
a kid no the Vivian one is no the Vivian
one I think is in in the UK but he has
another one that he got together the
Vivian one was like a stripper I'm like
what the we're we're fighting for a
stripper I don't know but he's I know
the one he got together with was like 16
or something like he was just like
barely legal and that's the one like he
basically controls right so that's
that's I know that's kind of what I've
what I've like heard from like yeah but
I'm just like what we're stupid at 16 I
was 16 like I don't know I just it's not
about being stupid it's about bonding
right like if you're with somebody at a
young age as a woman you will bond with
them more likely than if you get older
right so like oh I totally agree I just
say it's an L like I just I just think
like come on you're gonna you pick to do
c like okay at 16 you decided to hook up
with a multi-millionaire he got you to
do cam work and now like I just I don't
know she bonded with him like again he
would pre on these girls that were
straight out of high school like a lot
of the ones that were just straight out
of high school because they could still
bond with the guy right so I think that
that's part of the the strategy that
they use like there's all these videos
of him talking about his strategy and
that strategy is sexual exploitation
it's not trafficking like the the
traditional definition of trafficking
like you mentioned yeah but it's a
definition that has to do with right
like sexual exploitation coercion and
lying to basically uh sexually exploit
someone which is what they're what he's
doing right yeah I just I just kind of
look at those all is like feminist words
like and this is just kind of how I see
it where it's like you got all these
words to just make like to me it's just
like the chick made a stupid decision
I'm not saying what he did was right but
I'm like you know when I was 16 I was
playing volleyball these chicks decided
to go do cam work for a
multi-millionaire people make different
choices you know like I just would do is
he would go on Instagram and he would
contact girls that were straight out of
high school and then he would fly them
out and like woo them get them drunk and
then convince them right that's but like
in my head I'm like you chose to go like
like this is just this is just how I
think so I'm like that's the same thing
as like saying well you as a guy you
chose to marry her so now you're stuck
getting divorced and rap well I you know
I would somewhat agree if the guy like I
don't really see it as the same thing
because I just I think back to myself at
16 I'm like I wasn't doing that stuff so
why are you guys like where are your
parents this like why are you why are
you guys getting on a plane to Romania
but yeah well they're he's more looking
for the 18y olds yeah but the 16y olds
is the one he he made a relationship
with right so that's like and you know I
think that's kind of weird but it's like
it's leg it's legal it's legal right
it's like yeah so you know I'm not I'm
not here to say like that's a good
dating decision but do I think it's
worth human trafficking I I would
disagree you know but but based on the
legal definition it fits right that's
that's all that matters right well
that's the they just expand but that's
like the same thing as like you know
when I hear these guys that like get um
you know emotional abuse accusations I'm
like I I guess technically it falls
under it but like you know that nagging
nagging is emotional abuse I
know this is my point though I know this
is my point it's like so they expand the
definition and then they kind of gotcha
on the men and some of them are doing
sure immoral stuff but I'm like like do
they deserve 20 years for human
trafficking I would argue you know look
it's I I I agree with you like I he's
he's playing the system he's playing
these women who would have played some
other guy somewhere else but like they
also recognize that he's influencing a
lot of young guys and they don't want
that so that's one of the reasons
they're also going after him
so it's like a m it probably would have
slid if he hadn't become so big right
like this never would have happened yeah
so it's a combination of things right
like so now they're like digging up
every man's past it's like you know how
how do I know that somebody's you know
it find out finds out who I am and then
goes back and asks ex-girlfriends like
did he do anything and they're like yes
he did it's like but I didn't do any of
that well prove it and then all all of a
sudden I'm going away for 20 or 30 years
off of just like somebody's false
accusation that's ridiculous right yeah
with zero proof just he said she said
that's it I I think that that's the
completely different story right like
and so the like right now they went
after Danny Masterson he's going away
for life and who knows what's going to
happen to Russell Brand I think they're
gonna there's going to be a court case
for that probably so they're going to go
after him Cas well the the the the UK
government the police have already beun
the investigation now Danny Masterson is
that the that's the guy who was on the
70s Show he went away him I covered him
30 years and so there's Russell Brand
and who else have they been going after
recently uh I don't know like there just
there just all these cases constantly
popping up yeah so I'm like that's why
when you were talking about your future
I'm like well with these consequences
you're you're right I mean and the low
testosterone everything else we talked
about but I'm like I was a guy I just
wouldn't even touch women with a 10-
foot pole well I just I think that like
the thing is right now young guys have
access to so much pornography yeah that
it's like what I I found like things
like the Fleshlight would actually be
like in terms of feeling stimulation it
it's it's in some ways better than an
actual vagina which is kind of crazy cuz
like we're going to create technology
that's more sexually stimulating than
actual sex so why would anyone have sex
if all of a sudden there's technology
that does it better right like I think
that that's kind of the direction we're
heading in and then all of a sudden
people are going to be like well like
like a vibrator women use vibrators
because they get something that could
never get from a real person but I mean
even if you don't use it I'm just saying
like a lot of women do because I know I
know I know I'm not D not not saying you
said that but but I'm like but I'm like
ah this stuff is future is going to be
weird I have to go though um no worries
I have to go but thank you so much you
actually this is the first interview
that's made me like think about things
really different in a while so like you
kind of hopefully not depressing I feel
I'm a little depressed but it's all
right I'll get over it it's like when I
figured out marriage was dead it was
like depressed for a week then I was
like yeah it's all right so um can you
tell people where they can find you
maybe they should subscribe to your
second channel so no once mzed there's
Sandman too um if you just do a search
on YouTube you can find me there you can
like if you do Sandman mtow on like
rumble or bitshoot well bitshoot the
search Eng doesn't work there anymore
but yeah like YouTube Sandman 2 is
probably the best and it if you want
Rumble just Sandman MTA you could find
me there there too so well and then I do
go ahead go ahead no go ahead no I just
I do my uh like I do memes of the week a
couple times a week which are just like
uh all the stuff I post on Twitter the
most popular stuff for the for the week
which is kind of interesting and then I
do videos like request videos people
suggest videos video topics and I do
those and I also do coaching calls so
people can pay to talk to me for an hour
or two I I retweet you a lot on Twitter
the the Twitter yeah I see you on there
too you're like yeah there's a lot of
funny stuff there too yeah um okay so
guys make sure you subscribe to his
channel um I'm gonna put you on our list
for like panels we were going to do some
virtual ones I think it'd be really
interesting to hear some of your ideas
like with other people like I just think
it'd be really interesting so um cool is
that all right yeah that's cool okay but
yeah guys make sure you like the video
subscribe um seriously um his content is
so funny I think some of our best
reactions have been me showing like new
chicks your content is so funny um like
the video guys subscribe and I'll talk
to you next time